Speaker 1: Let's go next to Benjamin from Seattle.
Hi, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 8: Benjamin, so long time listener,
I actually have to moderate watching you on
YouTube, so I'm not too much of an echo chamber.
Good cause I agree with you a lot. My question
with Donald post regarding Donald Trump
since he was commander in chief, could he
be court martialed regarding Jan. six and
would that be better? Legally speaking,
Speaker 1: I don't believe so. I think,
you know, commander in chief
refers to the fact that
ultimately the president of the United States
is the commander in chief of the U.S. military.
But the president is a civilian in charge of the
U.S. military, and I do not believe they would be
subject to a court martial, right?
Speaker 8: My main question is, did
Donald Trump really accomplish anything in that?
I mean that some of the things that are considered
part of his administration, like conservative
Supreme Court justice is really Mitch McConnell,
right? Big tax cut. Paul Ryan. And then anything
else he did pretty incompetently like. The Muslim
ban was so badly done it had to go to court
several times. Yeah. So did he really accomplish
anything, except maybe just to stay out of the way
Speaker 1: that, well, he didn't stay out of the
way? Trump accomplished many things that were
all negative. He humiliated the world on a
global stage. He set us behind on climate. He Dr.
Deborah Birx earlier this week said that Trump's
failure on COVID probably led to 30 to 40 percent
more deaths than we otherwise would have needed.
So I think you're very much on to something
which is in terms of his campaign promises,
Trump did nothing. He did nothing, but he damaged
a lot of things. The absurd trade war with China
that did not benefit Americans. He did a lot of
things that were all bad. But in terms of what you
would call political accomplishments, he barely
did anything, and it's astute to point that out.
Speaker 8: So you mentioned the Chinese trade
war. Would you say that some people actually
think that's a positive thing, though?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I think there are some
people who think it is. They tend not to
understand what's going on when you actually
talk to them a little more deeply, though.
Speaker 8: OK, well, thank you very much.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thank you so much for the
call. Like getting right to the right, right to
the big substantive topics. Let's get to Taylor
from Atlanta, Georgia. Taylor, you're on the air.
Speaker 5: Hey, David and I come in, Okay.
Speaker 1: You're coming in, OK? Yeah, let's
let's keep going and see how it how it holds.
Speaker 5: OK. Yeah, sorry about that. I've
got the nod of bad call disapproval
before, so let me try to fix this,
please. But I just wanted to get your thoughts on
the trends of childhood vaccinations in the world
that's going on right now. I think we've walked
back a little bit based on the COVID vaccine and
just general childhood vaccines other than
COVID and what you're thinking is going on.
Speaker 1: And I'm not sure I
know what you mean. You're saying,
are there just more vaccine hesitant people
when it comes to their kids globally right
now as a result of the COVID vaccine debate?
Speaker 5: Yes. Yes. I think childhood vaccines
have been pretty, a pretty common thing, and
not giving a child vaccine has never been
questioned, as argues now.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I
do. Is there any reason to think that the COVID
vaccine debate is impacting other vaccination?
I mean, there have been these anti MMR
enclaves for a decade or more. I've not
seen any evidence that suggests beyond the
debate about this vaccine, that there's a
bigger anti-vax trend for kids going on.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I mean, there's been a
slight decline. I think W.H.O. has put out a
brief report on it, but that's been going on
since before COVID. OK, I didn't know. Usually
these metrics take a little bit of time
like you can't really look at 2021 just yet.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, I think in the long
term, it is going to remain clear that vaccination
has been one of the greatest accomplishments
of Homo sapiens for extending life and preventing
death. I think, you know, we might have there's
a lot of anti-vax madness in the US right now,
but I think that's the long arc of vaccination.
Speaker 5: Yeah, great. I
completely agree. I personally have,
you know, I work in that realm. I've seen I've
personally seen children die from these vaccine
preventable diseases, and it's it's horrible.
So I just I hope that that continues how you're
Speaker 1: saying you and me both. I'm
optimistic it will. Cautiously optimistic.
Speaker 5: Yes.
Speaker 1: All right.
Thanks very much for the call. I appreciate it.
We're going to take a very short break if you're
holding. Don't hang up because we are going
to get right back to the phones momentarily.